okay
good morning everyone
that's loud
good morning everyone i'm going to open
the subcommittee work session on house
bill 1186
it's uh relative to companion animals
during a declared state of emergency
just so we're all clear the subcommittee
members who can vote on this are
rep aaron
rep davis rep kennedy rep bixby rep von
plinsky rep perez and myself the chair
did you guys grab a copy of the
amendment that was there by your name
tags i'm sorry i meant to mention that
was there i'll give you just a second to
grab that
and for anyone else that would like a
copy then there's an amendment to house
bill 1186
over there on the table for anyone
that's interested
repeats but you want to grab a copy of
that amendment
okay so
we have i want to bring forward um
amendment 202207
which is an amendment to house bill 1186
i had this amendment drafted and it i
believe it reflects all of the changes
that we
had expressed for concerns with the
original bill during the
other subcommittee work session that we
had
has everyone reviewed the amendment and
you're comfortable with it
all right i'm not seeing any opposition
to that
we'll uh
we'll move the subcommittee into an
exact session on the subcommittee
and
i'm going to move
um
ought to pass as amended with amendment
2022-072-h
[Music]
on house bill 1186 and i'll look for a
second
okay repixpay is seconded
so we have a motion to
octopassism
uh we have a motion to pass the
amendment 2022-0727
h to house bill 1186
and i will uh
ask our acting cleric which is rep aaron
to
call the role
that's okay
actually you know what i think since
we're all in agreement we don't have to
do a roll call on this as a
as a subcommittee so could buy a show of
hands everyone that's in favor of this
any opposed not seeing any of the
amendment passes
so i will move ought to pass as amended
as a recommendation to the full
committee on house bill 1186 with
amendment 2022-072
h
do i have a second
rep bixby seconds and again we'll do a
show of hands all in favor
any opposed
so let the record show that it was a
unanimous vote by the show of hands
that was nice and easy and that's all we
have to do is a subcommittee on this so
it will move to the full committee at 11
o'clock
so with that i will adjourn the
subcommittee and the next subcommittee
starts at 10 30.
good morning
seeing that it is uh 10
i'd like to call to order the
subcommittee work session for house bill
hb 1454.
and with that i will
open up the floor for a brief discussion
about a potential amendment
um
so before us this morning
i have drafted an amendment based on the
collective work that the subcommittee
had been doing with regard to
time of travel concept
and i'd like to ask
representative
bixby
to briefly sort of talk about
the
stylistic outline of
what wyatt looks a little bit different
in format
okay so um
the
uh representative murray submitted this
to
ols and
they had some con
they
had some concerns about the formatting
um
so the first thing they said was that uh
the statement the
statement of purpose is something that
uh is part of the bill but it does not
end up in statute
it ends up in the record of the um
of how the bill has been processed
so they said the the this that would
have to be uh a separate paragraph at
the beginning
uh and it the statement of purpose is
essentially
uh exactly the same as uh well
the it is essentially the same as what
we had um
instead of saying whereas it says
statement of purpose um and then
uh it says
the protection of perennial rivers lakes
and coastal waters from contamination is
in the public interest of the state of
new hampshire
therefore
uh the setback and then
everything beyond that is
uh the same as we had in
the working draft that we
were looking at last week
the
uh
the other thing that they
uh said that they were concerned with
was
that uh the
um sequence of how the calculation is
done
and how the requirements are
uh or
um
or prohibitions are set up
uh needed to be done differently than
what we said in in order to
make sure that the
um
the
the calculation was
uh clearer for someone who'd be reading
it so
um the
uh the the changes that
uh
um that i've made he that i made here
are basically in order to
make sure that the calculation is done
correctly so uh
the term cites the uh in the first two
the first two lines are
very similar to what we had in the first
two lines of the first of the second
paragraph that we were working on
uh
and the only difference was i moved the
word site specific from the calculation
paragraph we had which was the third
paragraph
to the second paragraph
also it's the department show shall
establish a site
site specific setback distance
for any
proposed new landfill for from any
perennial river lake or coastal water of
new hampshire as defined
etc uh the setback distance shall be
sufficient to prevent any contaminated
groundwater
at any part of the actual solid waste
disposal area from reaching
any perennial river lake or coastal
water of new hampshire within five years
that is essentially
exactly what we had in the um
previous version
and then
for the calculation the setback distance
shall be calculated as followed
the applicant shall hire an independent
hydrogeologist at the applicant's
expense to estimate based on adequate
and representative
on-site field testing okay so that is
basically the same as what we had before
uh the seepage velocity of groundwater
in both overburden and
over burden slash till and better and in
bedrock
uh i removed the word maximum from that
sentence uh
because
what's the way this is going to work
when someone's actually on site is
they will determine based on the um
the
basic geology of the area and on the
size of the site
what would constitute an adequate and
representative sample and it might be if
if it's a very small site it could be
one test well it could be a test well
that tests both at on the overburden
until in one location
uh more likely if you're looking at say
a 20 to
20 acre
site for a landfill
then it would probably be
a half a dozen or so
and
the
um so the maximum seepage velocity would
be the highest reading from any of those
test wells they did on the actual
site of the proposed landfill
and then there's that maximum seepage
velocity is what gets used to figure out
uh
where that five the five-year distance
of travel estimate is so
what really matters is coming up with a
distance so
the five year distance of travel
estimate is calculated by multiplying
uh the max maximum seepage velocity by
five so
the
seepage velocity is in uh
feet per year you multiply that by five
you get what you the the distance for
five years
um
and the setback uh from any perennial
river lake or coastal water of new
hampshire shall be the greater of the
five-year distance of travel estimate
calculated in pair sub-paragraph two or
two hundred feet
uh so that actually make that actually
makes the uh calculation a bit clearer
than what we had
in the um
the draft text we were looking at last
week and then uh the
um
paragraph b has the clarifi the um
statement of
what would prevent a permit from being
issued which is no permit shall be
issued uh if
the new landfill site fails to conform
from that with that setback distance as
calculated in paragraph a
and then
in terms of making sure that
all existing landfills are held harmless
paragraph c says
nothing in this paragraph shall be
construed to prohibit the expansion of
any landfills that are in operation at
the time that this paragraph takes
effect
so that's uh that is the
uh the way
that the text has changed and
how essentially the the change text
really represents what we were feeling
pretty good about last week
thank you um representative bixby i will
also note in an effort to save paper the
amended analysis is on the back so just
go ahead and take a look at that
and i'll open the florida representative
class
thank you madam chair um
representative bixby um it is my
understanding that there are
applications already pending that people
have been going through the process of
site development for landfills in the
state of new hampshire it sounds like
you're changing with this bill it would
automatically change the requirements
for those applicants is this correct
um
if uh i
i am not quite sure how the
um
i i believe that would be correct but i
don't know if that i don't know what the
grandfathering the details of
grandfathering are
um
sorry thank you yes you may follow up
thank you um i am concerned
that um
changing legislation or rules in the
course of an application or anyone doing
business in the state
um
you know especially where the process
for getting a permit
has been cited to us could take up to 10
years
is
truly um unfair to
any proposed business or person
in the state that does business with new
hampshire what kind of message are we
sending
are there any other questions
oh
liv stapleton
thank you madam chair um i'm looking at
at uh line three in the amendment
uh relative to the question that was
just asked uh it says no permit shall be
issued by any division of the department
for the sighting
of a new landfill
if any part of the actual solid waste
disposal area
is proposed to be located sufficiently
close to any perennial river lake
coastal water of new hampshire etc
so it would seem to me by the by that
wording that that would have an effect
on
any current application that's
now before the des
i mean that's the way i read it
and i just thought i'd make mention of
that
to answer that question how would it
affect existing permits and i think it
does
i appreciate your thoughts um
representative com12 yeah also on line
11 it says for any proposed new landfill
which to me would be someone a new
applicant not an application process but
if you go down further to line 25 it
says the no permit shall be issued for
citing a new landfill so
um
i think there's some
it's ambiguous right now and i i don't
think
uh there should be a clause in here that
for any existing applicants with the des
they should be exempt
thank you representative uh
representative uh bolden did i see your
hand
okay
uh thank you madam chair just to address
the concern about there's an existing
project on the books that that this may
be interfering with that's really a job
for the courts to figure out as far as
how it would be grandfathered but also
our job is to set public policy we just
can't
um not set good public policy whenever
there's a proposed project that
someone's working on anywhere in the
state we could never do anything as a
legislature if we
always
just allowed
conduct that was happening to prevent us
from passing bills
thank you i'll just remind folks that um
to keep a level of of decorum and
issuing questions through the chair
please
thank you madam chair
and i agree with you representative
bolden
but usually when we are passing policy
we do usually have in some type of
clause or when there was another
policy that came through us
you know that where it says
except for anything prior to this or
that so um
usually when we are passing policy we
want to make sure that we're doing good
practice and we're not and i understand
that we are talking about groundwater in
the in the um the health of our state
um with this legislation and it's
important
thank you representative
follow up uh representative bolton uh
thank you madam chair i would just add
that the uh the project that i believe
is being alluded to
uh the the applicant doesn't even own
the property
so i'm not sure how far along that
process is but but they don't even own
the property at this
point is there sorry yes representative
conqueror question
representative bolden
um i am not sure about anything all i
know is that
the director said that there was an
application or applications in process
and i am not privy to all of that
information so
i'm just making mention
that that was mentioned in our
subcommittee
okay
are there any other thoughts
from the members of
representative stapleton
oh thank you uh madam chair
i want to correct
the reference of what i was reading
before which was in the original bill at
uh
the second
paragraph at uh 15 roman 15
parentheses a
in the amendment
at 08 94 h
that has been shortened
to the department shall establish
a site-specific setback distance for any
proposed new landfill
from any perennial river lake or coastal
water of new hampshire is defined in rsa
the colon 4.
what i had been what i had read before
and i apologize for that was the
original bill
which
had
extra
wording into it
and the amendment has
modified that
thank you representative
with that
is there
i know that the good work that we have
done within our subcommittee is
extremely important to this topic and
other topics that have come before this
committee and so at this time
we do have an additional
subcommittee work session starting at 11
o'clock i would like to
see if there is a motion
uh to entertain uh representative thank
you uh
you it actually since this is your um
your amendment it would make sense for
you to move this okay i thank you
so
i would like to move
that the committee adopt
the recom
the recommendation of ought to pass
the amendment
first i apologize
the amendment first and for
consideration
um and the amendment is 20 22 0
8 9 4
h
is there someone out there who will
second
that i'll second that madam sure thank
you
and will the
do we take a
roll call adam
okay
however you would like to do it i can do
roll call or show of hands whichever's
i'll just call the roll that's fine
um representative
thank you madam click call the roll
thank you
thank you madam chair
um
representative
uh
see
bolden uh yes
representative kaplan
yes
representative contoir yes
representative
tusick
okay
okay thank you
uh representative stapleton yes
represent pamola
yes
motion passes
oh madam chair sorry yes
excuse me so with that
um seeing that the amendment passes i'd
like to then see if there is anybody
i'll move it again
thank you
this is thank you very much i would like
to move that
house bill
[Music]
1454 fn
passes ought to pass as amendment
otpa ought to pass as amended and with
that i'd like to have the clerk call the
roll
no we need a second oh thank you
is there a second i'll second madam
chair
representative bolton
you're keeping me on my toes madam yes
is there any discussion on that uh
motion
i can open the floor for discussion yes
i recognize you
thank you madam chair
um
very nice work on the amendment
i know that was a tough job
clearing up language and you did on
several pieces
um
while i support the amendment
i'm unable to support the otpa
on the bill and and here's why it's
great it's a good bill and um i really
am a subscriber to
the time and travel setback
um i think several other states are
doing that with some success
maine even has a larger time component
of six years instead of five
but
i was reading over the weekend all of
the testimony
and i came into a stumbling block
that was pointed out by the testimony by
sanborn head
the hydraulist hydrologist there
who wrote the testimony
timothy white
and he supported
the formulation
made sense
but he said there's three problems with
the bill
and i'm only going to go into one of the
problems because i'm not sure about the
other two but representative i just also
we are talking about the bill now as
amended so as amended
exactly
uh and he goes on requiring the
immediate shutdown of a landfill if a
priority pollutant is detected in any
concentration baseline and why is that a
problem
because immediate shutdown has
a harmful and immediate impact
in the economy and the operation of
waste collection and disposal
and if you're shut down and the shutdown
could be extensive for
weeks
months maybe even a year and maybe some
of that
pollutant that may have been found may
not be from the landfill
and all these maybes should not be
an arbitrary determination to shut the
landfill down madam chair point of order
state your point of order i i believe we
were supposed to be confining our
remarks to the bill which has been
entirely replaced by the amendment i
believe what the representative is
speaking to is section c that was
deleted weeks ago
can we confirm that
would you thank you um could you
speak to just the aspects please of the
bill as amended
i guess i missed that um
okay amend the bill by replacing all
after the enacting clause with the
following okay um i missed that
important point
and so um
i will uh terminate my testimony right
there
thank you and with that are there any
other
points of discussion
yeah
um i would just like to just sort of
clarify for everyone that
uh the amendment has eliminated that
that portion entire the portion referred
to in the sandboard letter entirely so
uh there would be
no this this bill
would have no effect on representative
we
i appreciate that but we are now in the
voting
mode
so with that i'd like to
uh if there are no other thoughts could
we please call the role
point of order
this
we're in
uh subcommittee at this point correct
for recommending what to bring forward
to the committee to the full committee
for recommendation right thank you
representative bolden
uh yes represent kaplan
yes
representative commtois no
representative stapleton
no
representative pamola
yes
madam chair
one two three four four to two motion
passes
with that the recommendation
passes and we will close out the
subcommittee work session
on hb 14 54 fn
thank you
um
people's work
just for the benefit of everyone here
we're going to just do a quick caucus
here i'll try to get back in for 11
o'clock but we might be a couple of
minutes late gabbling in okay
good morning everyone
we will open the full committee
work session on um
1186 there it is there we go on house
bill 1186
we have two bills to take up today in
1186 and 1454 we're going to do 1186
first
so the subcommittee on anal animal
protection convened and wants to bring
forward a recommendation of otpa on
to the full committee on house bill 1186
you should have a copy of that amendment
if not there are some on the table and
that is amendment number uh 2022-07-278
does do the committee members all have a
copy of that
you don't have all right i'll give you
just a second to grab when they're on
the table over there
okay so what this amendment does is
it fixes a couple of points that we
discussed in the subcommittee that where
we found some errors in the bill and if
everybody's had a chance to read it
the overall concept of what we were
looking to do was
to make it so that
when folks had a mandatory evacuation
that they could
have the ability to have their companion
animals cared for as well because that
was expressed as a concern and it would
have some folks that would not
evacuate and so we
through testimony in the original bill
and in the subcommittee we learned that
there were a few uh critical errors that
we felt in the original language
and i believe we've cleaned them up in
uh in this amendment in the
work of the subcommittee
so this will
this will allow that when in a vacuum
emergency evacuation order goes into
place any hotel or community shelter
that shelters evacuated persons shall
allow for disaster animal response
trailers or other reasonable
accommodations on site to accommodate
any companion animal belonging to that
evacuated person
that was one major piece that was
important because originally the bill
would have
forced the animals to be kept in the
confines of the hotel itself with if
that if it was a hotel or a community
center and we saw a whole lot of
problems perhaps having some
non-compatible companion animals sharing
a common space
and so by
doing this amendment we learned that
there were
shelter trailers available
that would be made available during an
emergency evacuation and they already
exist within the state so
that was one of the things that we
wanted to make sure was that they had a
place to deploy those trailers that was
on sort of the same campus as where the
evacuated person ended up so that they
were there in the same area with their
animals
the second portion of this it provides
any volunteer who has been vetted by the
department of health and human services
and is a member of that disaster animal
response team
and assist you in assisting the
evacuated persons she'll be considered
an emergency worker under rsa 21p41
in essence what it does is extends
workers comp to
protection it's not exactly workers comp
but the same provisions of workers comp
so that if this person who is aiding and
assisting
in this response team is injured during
that practice then they
have some protection
and it doesn't fall back onto their
personal medical insurance
so that's kind of in a nutshell what
this does
and so that is why the subcommittee
recommended the
this amendment and the otp
recommendation on the whole bill otpa
recommendation so i'm going to open it
up now for any discussion questions from
members yes rep perez
thank you mr chair for let me speak i'm
grateful to see this amendment and i'm
grateful to see this bill coming through
as someone who
suffer from ptsd
heaven and animals
when is a
disaster or anything did you know that
i would love to keep my my my animal my
companions um
i have um
i have a rabbit i have a pet rabbit
believe it or not she's my companion and
i
you know i if anything happen and if any
decision happened i wish to have you
know my competing close to me because
it's like i say you know having ptsd is
not an easy thing to handle
but um so that's why i'm grateful and i
supported uh
uh passing to this
bill thank you rob bixby
yes thank you for taking my comment um i
just
want to uh
thank you for putting together this this
amendment and
um
i'd like to point out one uh uh
one other aspect of it that uh
you mentioned that there are that the
state does have trailers that are
designed for taking care of pets uh they
don't have an infinite number of those
and uh it is
uh one of the other uh changes in this
amendment allows for other reasonable
accommodations and that would make it
possible for uh
uh animal shelters or animal welfare
organizations to
um
provide uh
their
as a part of their organization's
mission uh not no expense to the state
uh additional shelters uh if um
if those were needed in order to
provide enough space for animals
thank you representative
repamola
yes chair thank you for taking my
question in the language where it says
obviously shall allow
does that leave it up to each facility
then to make its own decision on whether
it can or can't
take pets i just want to make sure i
understand the shell part
no so the the shell part requires them
to provide a location to put these
trailers someplace on campus or or some
other type of accommodation as bixby was
referring to but they would not be
required to put them in the building
where the people are
you're welcome any further discussion
without objection i'm going to take the
communion to exec session to exec house
bill 1186
and i will
make a motion to adopt amendment
2022-0727
h to house bill 1186.
do i have a second
rep reponsky seconds
is there any discussion from the
committee
on the amendment
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the adoption of amendment
2022-0727
representative aaron
yes
represent
yes representative abrami
yes representative
davis yes
representative stapleton yes
represent pamola
yes
representative kennedy yes
representative
yes
representative berry yes
represent bixby
yes represent suffolk she's not here
represent bolden
up representative akitas i am so sorry i
missed you
thank you um yes i vote for it
represent bolden
represent dutsy yes representative
murray
representative von plinsky
yes represent kaplan
yes
represent perez
verbs of nunning wong
yes
mr chair
one two three four five six
18 19 0.
some of them
excuse me
with a vote of 19-0 the amendment passes
and i will move ought to pass as amended
on house bill 1186 with amendment
2022-0727
h do i have a second
representative.c seconds
any discussion from the committee before
i call a vote
seeing none i will ask the clerk to call
the roll a vote on the vote of otpa on
house bill 1186 with amendment
2022-0727h
representative aaron
yes represent
yes representative abrami yes
representative davis yes representative
stapleton yes represent pamola
yes represent kennedy yes
representative tusick
representative berry yes
representative bixby
yes
representative safikidas
yes representative bolden yes
dutsy yes represent murray
yes representative von plinsky yes
represent kaplan yes represent perez
yes
representative nunning wong
mr chair yes 19-0
with a vote of 19-0 the uh
uh the motion about to pass is amended
on house bill 1186 moves forward without
objection we'll put it on the consent
calendar
seeing none
in the chair we'll do the majority
report on
house bill 1186
as soon as the clerk is ready we will
you're all set all right so we'll come
back out of executive session and go
into a regular session on
house bill 1454.
i will uh call on rep murray who led the
solid waste committee to
give us an explanation of the work that
the subcommittee did and the
recommendation that they provide
thank you mr chair um yes so i the
committee definitely did a lot of work
to
seek further clarity in
um
the groundwater contamination we sought
to address the the topic of leak spill
or other failures we also then sought to
address
perennial rivers lakes and other coastal
waters i know that that was important to
some members of the subcommittee and all
of our
work that we did together on that
and then um
the time of travel concept that we felt
was incredibly important we are seeing
regionally
um and across the nation
other um
states adopting this as part of their
method in their landfill citing criteria
and the committee did recommend that it
be ought to pass as amended
okay thank you
oh sorry pixby i can't see you over
there yeah go ahead so i just want to um
give a little uh run through of how the
how this bill is amended works um so uh
one thing that i think is important to
mention is that
uh there had been uh in the initial uh
and hearing on the initial bill there
had been um
a lot of concern about
the way that the third section of that
bill
addressed the consequences of a spill
that has been removed entirely from this
bill so uh there is um
there this bill is only
dealing with
a change to one number
that is in current um
uh current regulations and that number
is how far
a
uh landfill
has to be how far away a landfill has to
be from a
um
a river a perennial river lake or
coastal water as defined in state
statute
and
uh the current dis that current distance
is an arbitrary number of 200 feet
uh and what we have done is change that
to
a minimum of 200 feet but
a but the key number is
that uh
the number is
that distance is calculated by looking
at how fast the groundwater moves in the
particular area that someone is
proposing that a landfill might be
placed and
there is the
the ability to make
measurements
of groundwater movement is
uh something that science
hydrogeologists have been able to do for
at least 100 years it is a
well-established uh science
uh the uh
you can't uh some
the only
unpredictability in there is that you
can't predict exactly how something is
going to be exactly what the rocks are
going to be and soil is going to be like
over a long very long distance
but you can get a really good estimate
of how fast uh
groundwater travels
and the reason that groundwater
traveling is matters is that
groundwater is what would convey a spill
or leak to a sensitive water body like a
perennial river or lake
uh so
the idea is and we've laid that in that
out in the state and state and out of
purpose is that you want to make any
landfill far enough away from a lake or
river or coastal water
that if there is a problem
then
there is time to deal with it
so uh we have
consulting with various experts five
years is a reasonable amount of time to
recognize that there is a problem
and map the problem and then
figure out what to do about it it may
take longer than five years to actually
complete the the remediation uh in fact
sometimes the re remediation may have to
be a forever ongoing process
but
with by
noticing it within that five year period
you can
prevent it from getting to that water
body and that is that is the goal of
this bill preventing contempt potential
contamination from getting to a
sensitive water body
and
so
what the bill does the
paragraph two of the bill so paragraph
two of the bill basically lays out
how that calculation is made using
uh the
uh the maximum seepage rate which is
something that is
the result of doing on-site tests
the tests are always on the site of the
proposed water a landfill there they
don't go on to
any property around it
and
then an estimate is made from those the
maximum seepage estimate from the
various test wells that are on that
proposed
site
is what is used to calculate
uh how far away it need the
um
it would have to be or how far away
any water body would be to be safe in
that five year period
so um it's basically using a combination
of
well-known hydrogeology and
fairly simple
algebra to determine what
the uh what what an appropriate distance
is for a setback
and
in some cases uh if it is on bedrock uh
solid bedrock and um play
that that
um
that distance may be the calculated
distance may be less than the 200 feet
but 200 feet seems like
that's been working for a while for as
as a minimum
uh so it seems like
uh
using that 200 feet or
a calculated distance so if it's in a
sandy area
that the travel time might be much
faster and
contaminants could potentially travel
five miles within five years and that uh
that was so that would be um
probably a site that it
would be
less appropriate for a landfill so
but the
one of the key things about this is that
this is the test that is done very early
in the process so that
a
someone who's looking to cite a landfill
can determine before putting a lot of
money into it
whether or not that that uh proposed
site makes sense and if
the hydrogeology says no it doesn't make
sense then they don't spend a lot of
money trying to
uh
to cite a landfill where it doesn't make
sense so this is basically a way of
protecting the investment of someone who
would want to make
uh to want to sight a landfill
thank you representatives
i i commend the
study committee on the work that they
did i i think you've done a great job in
cleaning up a lot of the concerns that
were were raised in the original
language of the bill and
the the amendment
reflects uh a great level of detail and
commitment on the part of the study
committee so i want to
again commend them for the work that
they did here
now the narrow focus of the study
committee obviously was strictly on the
language of this particular bill
i guess one of the
concerns and reservations that
i have about passing the bill as a whole
is is more about the work we did on
house bill 1049 the study committee bill
we included
the
purpose of house bill 1454 as well as
many others within that study committee
and i think it makes it a pretty
complete study committee
charges that committee with really
looking at the complete landfill citing
criteria rules as it pertains to all
aspects other than just this
the narrow focus of this bill on the
200-foot setback
but
um so i
my concerns overall
are related to
passing
this bill
as a standalone bill where i want to
make sure that the
study committee has the ability to do as
it would
is charged to do in looking at that
that whole process of of citing a
landfill and all of the things that go
along with it
did the
i guess i'll throw this out to the whole
committee for a little bit of a
discussion here and i'd like some
thoughts on
on not just this bill as an individual
but sort of the whole process as a whole
if we're ready to have that conversation
i'm certainly willing too so anybody
else would like to
weigh in on on your thoughts on this
bill and perhaps the overall picture of
the study committee
representative contract thank you mr
chair um
there's a couple components here first
off i think that the amendment
was really well done
and um
and should be the piece of legit
piece of information going forward for
any committee
um
to look at because
we did do a pretty deep dive and the
language has been cleaned up from the
original bill really well
so when we're talking just about the
amendment i think that
that's a great piece of work
however i do agree with you that we did
establish a subcom another committee to
study all the criteria for citing
landfills and i think that now that
we've done our work that this should be
incorporated into that
representative abrami yeah
just for clarity i just want to
understand when you say study committee
are we talking about a joint committee
with the senate is this in a formal
study committee or a study committee of
the committee uh this would be a study
committee that was established in house
bill 1049 that would include a senator
right and what and mr what's the uh
due date is that november one or is it a
year plus number one plus a year i
believe it's november one i will have to
look to confirm that but i do believe it
was november 1. so it's not that far
away if it's november one as well
correct thank you
and for uh the benefit of those that we
have subs on our committee today first
off thank you for coming in and subbing
and um
we we appreciate yeah you're doing that
because i know it takes time out of your
day and uh
so the
the overall purpose of house bill 1049
was to look at
the the whole that whole section of uh
landfill citing criteria this was one
piece of it we had multiple bills that
we put together that we passed on the
house floor last last week of the week
for whenever our session date was but
representative bolden has some input
thank you mr chair i guess i have a
question for you about the um the study
committee bill that i guess we're
talking about um is there any kind of
moratorium in that bill because
obviously i think the fact that we're
studying that as a committee or as a
legislature indicates that we feel that
our
landfill citing criteria is flawed and
could be improved to protect the
interests of the people of the state of
new hampshire and i'm just wondering if
we're going to undergo that study for
another potential year or longer before
we can get legislation
uh put into place
based on the results of that study are
we going to prevent the sighting of new
landfills so that
our findings in the study in the future
will be
kind of honored uh for any new landfills
or will people be able to
build new landfills while we're busy
studying something
so my understanding that's a great
question
i'll i'll answer this way that the
you know i think our committee certainly
made it
a high priority to look at the landfill
siting criteria whether they're flawed
or not i don't know that we came to a
conclusion on that but we certainly felt
that it was within the purview of this
committee to look at the policy and it
had been many years since it had been
updated and certainly all of the
interest in you know in the bills that
were put in indicated that the
legislature at least members of it had a
real interest in
our solid waste management and the in
the sighting of these facilities so
you know i think
that this committee had bills last year
that we felt were
were important and the response has been
very overwhelming and wonderful from
members of the committee and other
members of the legislature with the
bills that were put in and
i think we've um made a good showing as
a committee that we feel the solid waste
policy in new hampshire is really
important and we want to take a look at
it so to answer that part of it as far
as a moratorium i don't believe that
there's one in place i think that the
current
rules would
would stay in place and they would even
if we passed
this as a standalone bill it would just
change one narrow section as it relates
to the 200-foot setback that that's my
understanding i'll certainly open it up
to other committee members if they have
different opinions
all right we've got multiple hands let
me go with rep marie first
thank you mr chair for taking my
question
the one question i did have and i i
don't have 1049 in front of me but
it does have a repeal clause correct
like it goes into effect and then once
the study committee is finished it
comes
i do have it here let me read it real
quick
you know i do not see a repeal clause in
here unless i'm missing it it does um
the report out day is november 1.
i wasn't sure if it
with study committees sometimes we had a
statement we intended to put one in i
know the conversation was had but i
don't know
but i do not see the language in here
i think that was something that i would
recommend representative dixon yeah i
think if if we somehow fail to get the
repeal clause in there maybe we need to
talk it to the senate when it comes over
there because i i would concur because i
know the intent was to have one in there
yes
uh representative dutsy
yeah just for clarification uh the bill
that we're talking about is hb 1049
correct
well the study committee bill is yes
and the elements of house bill 1454 are
included in house bill 1049 that's why
it's a relevant topic but uh just for
clarification we did not put in the epr
bill in that correct it uh 1049 is only
for the sighting of landfills we didn't
put in any of the other bills that we
talked about going to interim study is
that correct yes we did actually i don't
have all of the bill numbers that the
one you were talking about was the
producer responsibility yes that
language is in there as well
okay so
okay so basically 1049
um is the vehicle that we're going to
use where we put in a lot of different
bills relating to i mean we had
something for the bottle bill that we
wanted to study the epr that we wanted
to study is it my understanding that
some of those bills are under the
interim study of 1049
so they're under interim study with the
committee correct we we've retained them
in the committee so that we can look at
them again as we go
uh into the later part of this year's
session 1049 would establish a study
committee that would work on this
obviously have to go through the whole
passage and so it would be over the
summer and into the fall and then it
would make a recommendation for future
legislation on
several topics and i apologize i don't
have all of the bill numbers right in
front of me i don't believe the bottle
recycling bill was part of that i
believe we just i asked that
thank you mr chair you're welcome our
representative
yes chair thank you
um first of all i actually like to thank
rhett bixby before the work he did on
some on the language of the amendment
uh
one of the things that i
appreciated about that standalone was
that you greatly clarified the language
and you
you really just made it simplify to move
the ball down further
down the line with what you've done with
that bill um
i one thing i did want to point out is
that i i don't believe the des ever
testified that their current landfill
siting
criterion were insufficient this bill
did not come to us because des said that
they needed their errors or their
current curriculum for doing this was
not up to par
and i i do want to say that as a
standalone bill i actually
like 1454
in the but i do have concerns in the big
picture as it relates to 1049 and
studying trying to look at this as an
overall landfill sighting i do have
concerns that it may be putting the cart
before the horse
when it comes to uh passing this today
thank you
uh representative bixby
yeah i'd just like to to point out that
um
the
uh
the uh departments
are essentially uh not policy making
bodies departments are executive bodies
so when we establish a policy in the
legislature it is the department that
executes that policy
but
unless there is a specific
problem that they have in terms of the
mechanics of of
of execution
they don't necessarily come to us and
say we need to have a policy change
so
one of the things that
we do as a legislature is we look around
the country we look at changing
conditions we look uh in terms of the
way that
the uh that things are operating both in
our state and in our country and we say
oh
some other states have been having
trouble
with
contaminants moving to
moving from landfills to sensitive
bodies of water and they have as a
result put into place
uh modified uh
distances
to uh safeguard their water bodies and
uh what we can and
recognizing that we can proactively say
oh that's a good idea that's a policy
that would make sense in new hampshire
where we have so many sensitive water
bodies that are critical to our tourism
industry
uh
um i think that
the fact that des didn't come to us and
say please fix this doesn't mean that we
shouldn't be working on that policy
thank you representative
rapamola did you ever
just just really a question uh thank you
chair
i
understand what you're saying rep bixby
would des not have a responsibility if
they
found something to be flawed or
inaccurate inadequate to to bring that
to our attention
as well i just don't all i my point was
well i understand that they are they are
the
the executing body of legislature
uh i'm just saying that this they
themselves did not come to us and say
that
the people who are in charge of citing
landfills did not come to us and say
that what we have currently is
inadequate that's all i'm saying
thank you yeah and that is correct they
did not come to us but um but it it it
does but it doesn't mean that we can't
observe
and uh policies elsewhere and say this
makes sense for us
thank you rips off keita
thank you mr chairman um
when we're talking about um the need for
a bill like this
it did not come from des it came from
stakeholders in the northern kingdom
and the state of new hampshire has a
huge problem with water
there are cancer clusters all over this
state
and right now
we have a blooming cancer cluster in
merrimack
and so
what we need to do
is we need to listen to our stakeholders
and they came to us for remedy and they
came for remedy because a private
company
is bringing trash from outside the state
of new hampshire
as a business practice and they're
making money
and they they they they're talking about
their capacities for their landfills
well the stakeholders in the northern
kingdom came for remedy from us and
they're the ones that pay the taxes
they're the ones that live with our
decisions and we need to give them
remedy when we've first heard the first
um
section of this bill several years ago
many many many people up in the dalton
whitefield bethlehem area up there we
got more mail than any other bill that
i've seen before this committee
and they're asking for remedy
those are the people that we need to
listen to
i you know i can just say i don't really
care what des is up to i care about the
the citizens who voted for us who pay
the taxes and sent us here to to
represent
their
their needs of their communities and so
continually kicking this bill
down the road like a can
is not
taking the first step in solving a
problem so to put it into another study
committee
when we're just allowing private
companies to bring in trash we have to
the whole country the whole country has
to look
at trash waste management and all of
that but why
do we have to be so concerned about a
private company bringing impr trash from
out of state and then they talk about
our capacity for having more and more
and more landfills
i don't get it we're a small state with
a small population and we should be able
to manage our landfills with what we
have and increase the things like
recycling and and the things that we
need to do as a state but this the
people came for remedy to us
thank you thank you representative many
good points and all of those hopefully
will you'll bring to the study committee
and present them when they're looking at
it because they certainly are good
points and they're right online with it
so i have a multitude of hands i'll go
with rep aaron
thank you mr chair
so i just wanted to remind the committee
of what was passed on hb 1049 this study
bill
and the study bill includes
that the committee would study the
citing criteria for new landfills and
with a focus on community impact
environmental impact and public good
it also will be studying solid waste
policies in northeastern states that
could be adopted
adapted to new hampshire
we'll be studying the surety bonding of
landfills to ensure capacity to pay for
potential damages
also changing the definition of required
setback to landfills from water bodies
by establishing
standards that use the hydro
hydrological
characteristics
so in other words 15
um
14 hb 1454 is already in this
study committee
and then item number five is the
extender producer responsibility piece
of it and number six the role of
landfills and incineration and
preventing disposable wipes they've got
a lot of things to make a comprehensive
waste management package
in this study committee and i see
this hb 1454
as being a very
important
part of this study committee and i think
that
this current bill that we're looking at
1049 is an integral piece
and that the subcommittee's work on this
has really laid the groundwork
for that particular
definition of required setbacks for
landfills
will be will go a long way to help the
study committee with the information
that they've
gone through and compiled
it's there
and it will be covered the
reporting out for that
for 10 49 is november 1st so it's not
going to take um you know forever or
another year
but at least
what we will have
after this study committee is finished
is a comprehensive package of
legislation that can go in right away in
the next time we
have our legislature
okay representative bolden i know had a
hand up
thank you mr chair
um
the the representative who spoke earlier
is absolutely right we know our landfill
citing criteria is inadequate and we
know this because there are cancer
clusters near our existing landfills
this is a fact
i would support rolling this into a
study if the study included a moratorium
on new landfills however as far as i've
heard it doesn't
if you want to talk about putting the
cart before the horse
letting another super landfill be cited
while we study the issue is putting the
cart before the horse and i will remind
the committee the house
passed
the policy that we voted down in this
committee last year it is clear to me
that the house
supports
preventing this landfill from being
cited this particular landfill at least
while we study this issue and make sure
landfills are only placed
in places where it's appropriate
i just want to remind the committee
before we get way off track here we've
already passed 1049 we've already rolled
all this criteria into that study
committee so what we're looking at is do
we want to pass this bill as a
standalone bill even though we've
already charged
the study committee with doing this so
just a reminder okay we seem to be
deviating just a hair there which is
which is fine and certainly looking at
all of us here can i follow up just
certainly thank you and and to that
point my argument is that we should pass
this bill because i think this is a
minimum amount of protection for our
citizens in the north country that
they've been asking for
while we study the larger issue thank
you thank you representative uh
representative perez had her hand up for
a bit thank you for having to give me
the opportunity to speak up
i would love to get the support for this
bill we've been working so hard since
last year and i believe yes it is a good
idea to have a subcommittee but this
bill alone i think is what we need and i
believe this is what we need
areas like milford already struggling
with water contamination merrimack
already struggled with water
contamination how much longer are we
going to stop these bills to pass how
much longer are we going to put it in
subcommittees our community is asking us
to do the right thing in passing this
bill right now
i believe it's the right thing to do for
us thank you so much
representative safidas
thank you mr chair the first
thing i just want to throw out is that
new hampshire has the highest rate of
bladder cancer in the whole country and
the area from merrimack all the way over
to the seacoast is a whole band of
high bladder cancer
and so
when you talk about treatment from
cancers
early treatment is the best and so
it's it seems to me that what we're
doing is we are sacrificing people's
health
for
a study committee
and the other thing is
just as an aside
people's homes and their private wells
is their biggest life investment and if
your water in your well is polluted you
cannot sell your home you no longer have
an asset
so i just don't see another study
committee when the people have come to
us asking for remedy
the other thing i would like to say
publicly and it's probably not
appropriate but that's okay
i have never been allowed to be honest a
study committee
from this committee
and so i would publicly like to say if
this goes to a study committee then i
would expect
that i would be invited to be on it
thank you well thank you represent
representative i just want to remind you
what's already gone to a study committee
it that that's not what we're voting on
it's already part of the study committee
and as far as the placement of the
members he'll
please make your request known to the
speaker's offices they're the ones that
will establish who is on it but okay uh
representative bixby i'll go over here
next yeah so uh what i'd like to focus
on is just sort of getting back to why
why it makes sense to do this bill now
as opposed to
waiting for
looking at the entire context of 1049
and one of the things that i have
had the experience of in
five years as a five terms as a
legislator is trying to
look at an entire
chapter of
law and fix it all at once
and
it was the worst decision i ever made
uh it was
there were many small components of what
i did which we have now worked through
but
trying to do it all at once
in one big bill
was a disaster
and when you have so
my feeling is that when you have a small
bill that you have right it doesn't make
sense to put off passing it
uh and we have this right and i think we
should pass it now
thank you representative and i i do
remember that bill and it was a
nightmare for you and and certainly the
uh the study committee could recommend
several small bills not all in one large
one which i think generally is good
practice
okay uh rep dot c then i'll go to rep
murray
uh thank you mr chair um
the last couple of months i've been
spending a lot of time on webinars
regarding recycling reducing
and reusing
yesterday i did a webinar on dirty dirt
where a number of companies private
companies all of them
came together to talk about the problem
that they have of waste disposal with
dirty dirt
was an hour and a half they didn't
conclude anything except it's still a
problem but what i see over and over
again is that
every single piece of this huge issue
that we have with solid waste management
every single piece
is an enormous project on its own
whether you're talking about glass
recycling you're talking about dirty
dirt you're talking about asphalt
recycling uh construction and demolition
debris
bottle recycling
epr i've been working for two years
doing research on an extended producer
responsibility for
tire disposal used use tires it's a huge
problem
when i had my tires replaced recently i
spoke to the owner about this and i said
apparently in new hampshire we don't
have a problem because every time
that i try to talk to somebody about it
they tell me we don't have a problem we
recycle we reuse these tires and they
all go to maine where we use we get a
tire derived fuel
and he laughed at me and said talk to
contractors he said every time they dig
up someplace for a new house he said
they find a load of tires that have been
disposed illegally and in fact on the
nashua conservation commission we're
dealing it with it right now so what i'm
saying is is that i think each one of
these issues is such a huge problem
that to put hb 1454
into an omnibus
interim study bill where you're talking
about disposal of wipes which when we
talked about that in public hearing we
recognized it was a a huge issue and it
was going to take a lot of work to
figure out how to produce a bill that
was adequate there when you have
epr thrown into that same bill and i
recognize how difficult that is to try
to piecemeal and come up with some kind
of legislation
i think we're doing a disservice to this
bill hb 1454 if we put it into an
omnibus bill like that
and i would like to support pulling it
out and passing it today thank you
so just as a process update
we've already put it in house bill 1049
okay
passing this won't pull it out it still
would allow
the study of it it's what this would do
is it would put this language into
statute and if the study committee found
that there were some problems with it
they would then have to change it so
that that's what would occur just as as
an update okay
we wouldn't be pulling it out of house
bill 1049 to pass this today okay
uh
boy i got hands all over again i'll go
with red bull and i haven't been over
there in a while
thank you very much mr chair just to
clarify i i think what a number of
members are saying
when they say rather than roll this into
a subcommittee or a study committee i
think what they're saying is rather than
merely having this as a subcommittee
just a simple language adjustment there
my apologize apologies right murray i
did was supposed to call on you next so
go ahead it's not a problem thank you mr
chair i just i would like to take a
moment to say how incredibly grateful i
am for the work that the committee has
and continues to do on this subject and
and many other things around
environmental issues
and i think that we are we are keenly
aware that we
have an opportunity to address some of
the most pressing
issues around water
drinking water whether it is a resource
such as a perennial lake or river
and
my desire in seeing this bill move
forward on a standalone would be that we
are taking a proactive measure instead
of a reactive measure
so with that um i'll just leave my
thoughts there
thank you representative bixby yeah so
uh in terms of
the relationship between
this standalone bill and the uh and this
uh 1049 study committee bill
uh
we the 1040 united society committee
bill is going to be looking at an awful
lot of stuff
and
if we can pass this now
uh because we know it's good now
then that's one thing that we don't need
to spend as much time on in the 1049
study committee we can we we can say
okay we solved this part so we don't
need to spend as much time on this we
can focus on other aspects
thank you representative i guess i would
say in response regardless of whether we
pass it or not there's been great work
done on this bill by the by this
subcommittee and i i really appreciate
that and it will you know
if this bill isn't passed right this
minute and we at least have a great base
to work from and i i am greatly
appreciative of the work that the
subcommittee did on this
do we have any further discussion or
representative stapleton
thank you mr chair um
we've done a lot of debate
and we're taking
a lot of time
and that's a good thing
um everybody who spoke here um has
brought important information to this
debate
to this issue
and i get an open question
don't expect an answer but more or less
for thought
is the study committee combination of
bills
and a standalone bill mutually exclusive
or not
that's
i don't want an answer i just
food for thought
it seems to me that the amendment which
is a fine piece of work
and i commend the authors for it
stripped out a lot of what we had as
concern and that strip out material is
going to go into the study committee in
and that's a good thing
and it seems to have removed some really
sticky items of concern that were in the
original bill
so i thank um
for the i'm thankful for the debate for
all the points of view and for the fine
job on the amendment and that's all i'm
going to say thank you mr chair
and just as a
sort of a follow-up to that i i do
appreciate the debate myself i think we
have a great great committee and
certainly no offense to the members of
the other committees that are sitting in
the substitutes but we're the best
[Laughter]
and it is my intention the bills that we
interim studied that
we included in part of 1049 my hope is
as long as the time permits in the
speaker's office will allow it is that
we will hold some interim study hearings
on
those subjects to continue to build the
base and make the
1049 study committee
have a lot
more detailed and better information
when they do convene to start with to
hopefully take the workload off from
them because i do know we put a lot in
there and i fully recognize that and i
think that we as a committee can
do a lot of the base work ourselves and
provide some great information to those
members who are assigned to that study
committee
excuse me
any
further discussion uh representative
perez
my luck starts about 1454. i will ask to
the support for this standalone bill
this committee we work really well you
know we we support each other and i feel
like are we so positive when it comes to
like find a middle ground and i thank
passing this bill along stay alone bill
yes like you said we already have it in
a subcommittee
but if anything that needs to be changed
when they study this bill in the
committee it's great if we pass it now
the way it is
and then if any changes that needs to be
done they can be done with the
subcommittee but i really appreciate if
we can get support for this bill right
now
thank you representative any further
comments
from the committee
i think we
we've had a very good and thorough
discussion on this and um
so at this point uh
i'm going to look go into executive
session if there's
no objection from the members of the
committee and we'll uh we'll address
this bill and see if we can come up with
a full committee recommendation
we have a subcommittee recommendation
uh from
the uh from the subcommittee excuse me
we have a recommendation from the
subcommittee to uh of otpa
on this bill so i'm going to honor that
and i'm going to look to representative
murray to
bring a motion forward from the
subcommittee
thank you
excuse me thank you mr chair i'd like to
make a motion
um to
um
so you want to move the amendment yes i
want to move the amendment which is
2022-089-h
uh zero eight nine four eight thank you
okay thank you
that's okay
all right so you're moving uh the
adoption of amendment correct okay do i
have a second
all right representative calm 12 seconds
so we have a motion to move amendment uh
202 to
202-0894 h
was uh moved and seconded do we have any
further discussion before we call for a
vote representative comta thank you uh
mr chair i do believe that the amendment
uh cleaned up a lot of language from the
original bill and should be adopted
thank you representative aaron
thank you mr chair
yes i want to really commend the
subcommittee for the work that they did
on this amendment it's really
some really good language and
i appreciate
the hard work and time that they took
to
refine the language and go through
all of the testimony so thank you very
much for
that any further discussion
seeing none i'm going to ask the clerk
to call the role of adopting amendment
2022-0894-h which is an amendment to
house bill 1454.
representative aaron yes represent
yes representative abrami yes
representative davis yes representative
stapleton yes represent hamola yes
represent kennedy yes represent
represent barry yes representative bixby
yes representative suffocatus yes
represent bolden yes represent dutsy yes
rosa murray
yes representative
yes represent kaplan
yes represent perez
yes represent nottingham
yes
mr chair yes 19-0
the vote of 19-0 the committee adopts
the amendment
2022-08948 and i will look to
representative murray for a another
motion
yes thank you um i'd like to make a
motion of ought to pass as amended for
house bill 1454 fn
do we have a second
representative bixby seconds
any discussion from the committee
well i'm going to offer up a little
that's the chair
oh did we have some i'm sorry
representative vicks we go ahead so i
think that uh we recognize that uh
we've gotten the language for this bill
correct and
when you have something that works
it's time to go forward with it
thank you representative bixby
while i
agree that the language for the
amendment is
excellent they've done a fantastic job i
still have the same concern that i've
had and i've yet to have it debated that
we
move as if we move this forward as a
standalone bill that we
are taking away some of the you know
what we've um charged the study
committee for in another bill that this
committee unanimously supported
and so i
have reservation about doing that and i
feel that while this is
excellent legislation you know the
language is good but it would it would
be best served as a complete package and
once it's looked at and understood as to
how it relates to the entire section of
landfill siting criteria and
and i haven't yet seen that passing this
bill at this point in time
will have any impact on any current
applications that are in play and that's
another concern that i had and i did
reach out to the department of justice
through the department the des
department of environmental services and
they would not provide an official
response
to that because they didn't represent us
as the legislature
but
i have concerns that we are going you
know that we would have the
effectiveness of putting new rules into
place with an existing application
that's currently pending so i have some
concern about doing that
but my real concern is that i want to
make sure that the study committee has
the ability to do everything that we've
charged it to do and i think we've
provided a great base of information for
it representative bolton
uh thank you mr chair i have a question
um
you stated that if we passed this it
would take away some authority i think
is what you might have said um from the
the study committee would the study
committee not be able to review the
changes that that we've made to statute
as well and have full authority to make
any recommendation they choose i believe
i said ability if i said authority was i
missed that
mistake misspeak on my part well they
certainly can there's no question that
they can still look at it but i when
when i look at a problem
that i go through with with my farm and
my own business i i hate
to have pieces taken off the table are
made more challenging and i think by
passing this we just
we don't gain a lot immediately and i
think that we put in place
just something else that has to be
looked at and changed and i think we've
got a really good base here i really am
supportive of the work that this
committee has done i think it will be an
excellent piece of recommended
legislation that will come from the
study committee this fall and i just
have yet to be convinced that passing it
now
moves us ahead any you know any great
distance because i
just did i yet to be convinced of that
so
follow up certainly
thank you mr chair um i just a question
if you had a fire on your farm would you
put it out first or would you study what
caused it
well i think that's sort of a rhetorical
question and and i don't
know that i need to answer that one but
thank you for it
uh representative dutzy
uh yeah my first career i've mentioned
this before was as a social worker and
one of the tenets of social work is that
when you are confronted with a huge
problem
uh you partialize it so you pick it
apart
and you uh you put it into small pieces
so that you are able to solve that one
piece and then you move
you have a plan and you move it forward
and i think that's exactly what we're
doing here we're looking at a huge plan
um we have studied this i i came in in
we've been studying this for
about three years now
we
were told during the public hearing that
the bill that we started with was one of
the best bills that they've ever seen
we've improved upon it
and i think we should partialize it by
going ahead and
passing this bill now
you know if there's issues that the
interim study committee finds
they can deal with it then but i think
this is exactly the way that we should
deal with it is by passing this bill now
on a partial basis and moving the whole
issue forward
again for clarification
this bill is gone uh that
the purpose of this bill in house bill
1454 is part of house bill 1049 which is
a study committee not an interim study
committee and i'm sorry and i'm not
trying to be technical i just don't want
to confuse people
in okay anybody else representative
perez
sorry and and i totally get what you're
saying
repeatedly the study committee
um hb
1049 but
in reality if we pass this bill
stay alone we're going to prove the
citizen in new hampshire that we're
taking seriously the problem that is
happening right now
yes we're going to work in 10 49 and
we're going to keep continuing working
on the other issues that we have
by passing this bill
the only thing is going to do is prove
that this committee it cares about what
is happening right now and then we
working towards getting
the right things
to happen to to fixing the other issues
that we have in hp 1049 but i really i
really really
think that and then i
i'm 100 sure that if we pass on this
bill we proven we proven our community
that we are doing the right thing and
then we're moving forward to finding
the remedy for the other issues so i
will ask
for the support to pass hp 1454
stay alone bill
thank you
excuse me thank you representative any
further comments from the committee
all right seeing none then we'll uh we
have a motion on the table of ought to
pass as amended on house bill 1454 with
amendment 2022-08948
and i will ask the clerk to call the
role
representative aaron
no representative
no representative abrami no
representative davis
representative stapleton
yes
representative ola
no
representative kennedy
representation
representative barry no
representative bixby yes
represent south akitas
yes
represent bolden
yes represent dutsy
yes represent murray
yes
represent von plinsky
represent kaplan yes
who did i miss
representative perez
yes represent netting wong yes
mr chair no
motion passes ten to nine okay so with a
vote of ten to nine the otpa
passes on house bill 1454 with amendment
2022-0894-h
so obviously this bill will not be on
consent uh representative murray you
wish to do the majority report i'll
happily do that okay i'm assuming
there'll be a minority report uh
representative comptoin did you want to
volunteer
no but i will
i thought i remember just saying yes you
did
representative murray thank you what and
the deadline to get those to you is
i would s today is tuesday if you can
get them to me by
noon tomorrow i'm not positive if
they'll be in next week's calendar or
not and my apologies i didn't ask so i
don't know that
yes
it is not and i
but if we are getting them in tomorrow
will they go in next week's calendar is
what i don't know
i'm not sure on that so
yeah so if you get them into me tomorrow
i will quickly get them to the committee
and i'm not certain whether they'll make
the next session or the following window
chairman pearl
representative i just wanted to um
clarify and i'm not sure of the
procedure but i just wanted to make sure
that that we all understood what we were
voting on that we were voting on ought
to pass with the amendment yes versus
interim study so well there was no the
motion on the table was out to pass as
amended
and that passed so no further motion can
be accepted
representative
i don't think we mentioned if hb 1186 is
going on consent i would assume yes we
did thank you
anything further from the committee
and i want to wish representative perez
a happy birthday
[Laughter]
i'm i'm not always good at recognizing
but this time i got one
all right well listen sorry it feels
good to be 18.
i'm not sure i remember that one
listen i want to thank the committee and
i want to thank our subs again today for
coming in i appreciate all of the good
and respectful
dialogue that we have as a committee and
i really do so thank you all and with
that we will close this session
representative
i wanted to share with you before
thursday